では、三帰依、五戒文から
始まります。
皆さん、合掌してください
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sammā Sambuddhassa
Buddhaṃ saraṇaṃ gacchāmi
ブッダ（佛・覚者）に帰依いたします。
Dhammaṃ saraṇaṃ gacchāmi
ダンマ（法・真理）に帰依いたします。
Saṅghaṃ saraṇaṃ gacchāmi
サンガ（僧・聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします。
Dhutiyam pi Buddhaṃ saraṇaṃ gacchāmi
ふたたび、ブッダ（佛・覚者）に帰依いたします。
Dhutiyam pi Dhammaṃ saraṇaṃ gacchāmi
ふたたび、ダンマ（法・真理）に帰依いたします。
Dhutiyam pi Saṅghaṃ saraṇaṃ gacchāmi
ふたたび、サンガ（僧・聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします。
Tatiyam pi Buddhaṃ saraṇaṃ gacchāmi
みたび、ブッダ（佛・覚者）に帰依いたします。
Tatiyam pi Dhammaṃ saraṇaṃ gacchāmi
みたび、ダンマ（法・真理）に帰依いたします。
Tatiyam pi Saṅghaṃ saraṇaṃ gacchāmi
みたび、サンガ（僧・聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします。
五戒文
Pānatipātā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
「生き物を殺さない」という戒めを
私は受けて守ります。
Adinnaadaanaa veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
「与えられていないものを取らない」という戒めを
私は受けて守ります。
Kāmesu micchācārā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
「淫らな行為をしない」という戒めを
私は受けて守ります。
Musāvādā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
「いつわりをかたらない」という戒めを
私は受けて守ります。
Srāmeraya majjapmādaṭṭānā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
「放逸の偈人となり（人を）酔わせる酒・麻薬類を使用しない」という戒めを
私は受けて守ります。
Sādhu  Sādhu  Sādhu
慈悲の瞑想はじまります。
ご一緒に
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願いごとが叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
私は幸せでありますように
「私は幸せでありますように」と
繰り返し念じます
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
私の親しい生命の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の親しい生命の願いごとが叶えられますように
私の親しい生命にも悟りの光が現れますように
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
親しい生命が幸せでありますように
繰り返し念じます
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
と繰り返し念じます
はい、ありがとうございます。
では、宜しくお願いします
今日の説法のテーマは、皆様のどなたかから出された質問なのです。
だからといって質問の言葉、文章通りに喋ることはないのです。
ポイントだけ仏教的に分析してみます。
質問は「人助け」ということ。
「よく分からないことで、どういうことかと、説明して下さい」ということですね。
英語でタイトルを入れたのですが、ちょっと日本語とはニュアンスが違いますね。
Being Helpfulという、
自分自身がどうやって、そういう
人間になるのか、という意味なのです。
今日はスライドの状態はそれほど良くないかも。
自分でデザインを何もしないで、そのまま、
あるもの、既定のものを使いましたけど、結構、面倒臭かったし。
まず我々は命の法則を理解しましょう。
命の法則。
「命とは何ですか？」ではなくて。
この「命」ということは、単立・単独で成り立ちません。
突然命が現れて、自分だけで生き続けることは、あり得ないのです。
他人の助けがあって、今、私たちは生きています。
だから、私が生きているということは、
ものすごい人々の助けがあって、
支えがあって、やっと成り立っているのです。
それをものすごく精密に理解した方が宜しいのですね。
これは日本の伝統的に言う言葉を使うとよく解ります。
私は、ちょっと
それは智慧の言葉ではないのですから
使いたくないのですが、
この「生かされている」という言葉。
「生きている」ではないのです。
それで、「生かされている」
「誰によって」というと、
そこはちょっとハテナ（？）で、
あらゆるもの
いろんな生命、
環境、
いろんなものに、
支えられていて、
だから、生かされているのですね。
「私は生きてるのだ」ではないのです。
言い換えれば、「ローンを組んで作り上げた命です」
だから、助けて頂いて
助けて頂いて、とかね。
「あんた、返したんですか？」と。
だから肉体を維持するためには、酸素が必要。
我々は、かたっぱしから、酸素を吸うわ、吸うわ。
二酸化炭素を出すわ、出すわ、とかね。
「なんかそこ、借りるばかりで、なにかお返しをどうしよう」それを考えることはないんですよ。
だから我々はローン人生なのですね。
ローンを組んで作り上げた命です。
幸福を目指す人、理性のある人は、借りを返すことに励むのです。
だから、ただ、その他大勢の良い人間生命ではなく、ちょっと理性があるならば、
「あ、なんか返さなくてはいけないんだ」と感じるのです。
「誰もが人を助けたい」という気持ちだけ、本来的に持っています。
面白いことは、どんな人間であっても、人助けは悪いと思わない。
「人を助けることが出来れば良いな、有難いな」とか、気持ちを持っているのです。
それは全然宗教とか、文化とか、関係ないのです。
人間なら人間なら知っているんです。
人を助けてあげなくてはいけない、と。
その気持ちを実行するか否かは別な話です。
だから、誰でも人を助けてあげたいという気持ちはあるのですが、
「あんた、本当にやってますか、やってないか」ということは
それぞれ個人個人の問題になるのです。
だから、論理的にそれをやるべきだと思ってます。
これは論理的ではないのです。
これ、ちょっと違うのですね。
他人を助ける人が自ら、
充実感、幸福感を感じる秘訣は、
その人が「命の法則」に逆らっていないかどうかにあります。
これ、ちょっと文章がおかしい。
我々は生きている上で幸福を感じたり、
充実感を感じたりする瞬間、瞬間があるのですね。
その時にチェックすると
「なぜこの幸せを感じているのか？」とか。
何か、自分の方から、何かをしてあげてるんです、他の生命に。
ということは、ほんの僅かででも、自分が借りを返しているのです。
借りを返したことは、命の法則を守ったことなのです。
命の法則を守る人は気楽に生きられます。
法則を破る人は、ハチャメチャ馬鹿を見て、苦労して
途中で命が潰れてしまいます。
それほど難しくない。
出来るだけ早く終わって、皆様の色々、具体的なご意見に答えたいと思います。
ですから、私は、ちょっと、ふざけたスライドを作りましたけど、
「You are happy」。
あなたは自由を喜びを感じています。
You feel freedom。
無数の生命があなたを助けているからです。
Because countless number of lives have supported your life,
and that will be continued further.ということで、
まぁ、私が言いたいことは英語でやりますけど、
あなたは、ハピネスを感じるならば、
たくさんの人々があなたを助けているのです。
「あー吾輩は自由だー」とか言ったら、後ろにすごいサポートがあるのです。
そのサポートが、それからも続くのです。
サポートシステムがなくなったら、その人にハピネスもないし、
自由もないし、生きづらいし、生きられないのです。
それから今までのポイントは、
人助けということは、我々は気持ちとしてみんな持っている。
私は後で書きましたけど、これは生命の本能なんです。
他の動物生命を見ても、結構助けていますよ、仲間を。
自分に分かる範囲で、「自分が助かってます」という範囲で、
お返しをしてるのです。
だから、やらないのは人間だけかもしれませんけれど
まぁ、我々の本能だと理解しましょう。
「人を助けたい」という気持ち。
なのに、人を助けようと思ってしまうと、トラブル、
トラブル、何一つもうまく行かないのです。
だから、借りを返したいのだけれど、これもうまく行かない。
窓口は閉まってるとか、ローンの場合は。
今は、ネットであれこれやり取りをやっていますけれど、
例えば自分のローンは、自分の口座から、入れようと思ったら、
そこでシステムがストップ、拒否したら大変なことになるのですね。
それから、あなたは払ってないでしょう、と。
でも自分が払おうとしたところで、システムが自分の送金を拒否しちゃったんです。
一般的な、いくつか思い出すたびに出して書きました
「人助けが恥ずかしい」と。
「人助けって、あの人に迷惑じゃない、そんなのは」とかね。
こういう言い訳するのですね。
「どうすれば良いか人助けになるか、よく分からんや」という人もいる。
また「私は人を助けるどころじゃない、自分の問題で精いっぱいだよ」と。
「人のことを構う暇がありません」という人もいる。
「私のことを嫌がっている、人を助けたいけど、
私のことをみんな嫌がっているのだから」
「私のことを嫌いと思っているのだから、
もう助けられませんね」という風に思うケースもある。
あるいは、言い訳。
「私は愛されなかった。かなり色々苦労して生きてきましたよ」と。
「十分まわりから愛されて面倒見てもらわなかった」という不平不満。
だから「なんで助けてあげるんですか」と。
「それはやらん」という人もいる。
或いは、何か人の事を好きになれない、人嫌い。
人のことを嫌いになってしまったら、人を助けられないでしょう？
「親のこと嫌い。親も助けてあげない」
友人であっても、「あの人のこと凄く大嫌い、嫌い」と。
リストを見ると、これかなり精神的な病気でしょうね。
詳しく説明する必要はないと思いますけどね。
ですから「私のことを嫌がっている」というのは、
自分の主観的な気持ちでしょう？自分の妄想でしょう？
人が自分のことを嫌がっているかどうかよく確かめてもいないしね。
自分になんか、精神的な問題があるのですね。
人は、どう思ったとしても「こんにちわ、お元気ですか？」という風に
明るく言うことができなくなってしまっているのですね。
「（自分は）愛されていない」ということもね。
私のこと「こういう風に、こういう風に、面倒を見た方が良かったのに」
私が「おもちゃを買ってくれ」と言ったとたん「はい、わかりました」、
「はい、どうぞ」と、親が買って上げなくてはいけなかったでしょう。
でもお金ないのだから
「あんた、前に買ったおもちゃがあるでしょう、それで遊んで下さい」と。
「言われたんだよ」と。これで腹が立って、恨みをもって、80歳になるまででも。
だから、not healthy、健康的でない。
病気です。
ここで、まとめて言うと、自分のことを低く評価する方々の問題なんです。
これって、エゴなのですね。
「私」というエゴなのです。これは「魔」なのです。
だから、自分の手足に鎖をかけられてしまって自分は本来、
足があったら歩ける、手があったら動かせる、仕事ができる、
鎖をかけてしまうと、どうしようもないでしょう。
だからエゴという「魔」が、「悪魔」と言ったら、
一般日本語ですけど言わなくても「悪」なんですね。
（「悪」という意味が）入ってます。
あの質問した文章にもあったのですが、面白くないフレーズね、
「コロナ禍で人々はかなり」って、私は問題にもしないのですけれど。
そういうことよりも、我々は、エゴが入って、
自分の本来の生き方を全部抑えて、邪魔をして、不幸にさせるのです。
そこで、自分を低く評価する。
評価するために「エゴ」という妄想概念が必要です。
私はエライか、低いか、とかね。
はい、それで次のスライドに行きます。
問題の続き。傲慢。
これもエゴですよ。
プログラムがガチャガチャ文句を言うから、ちょっとタイトルに違う単語を入れたんです。
本当は、同じタイトルで宜しいと思いましたけれどね。
エゴの到来と。魔の到来と。
私に「余計な迷惑」。
余計な迷惑、人を助けるということは「なんで余計なことをしなくちゃあかんか」と。
他人のことは、私に関係ない。
人は悩んでいようが、泣いていようが、私に関係ないよ。
（なんかちょっと、点が入って）
そこで、人助けというのは、好きな人がやればよいでしょう。
人はそれぞれ好みがあるのですからね。
「人を助けたい、助けたいと思っているアホがいれば、やれば良いでしょ。俺はやらんよ」と。
「そんな興味ないや」という人もいる。
あるいは政府、社会福祉組織。
これは個人で「なんで私がやる？それは政府がやれよ」
「色々WHOやら、ユニセフやら、いろいろ組織があるでしょうに」と。
「それ、そちらの仕事。そちらでやって下さい」という態度の人もいますよ。
あるいは、また偉そうに「人の幸せ、というのは、その人が築くべきでしょう」
「それであるバカが生活が悪くて、生き方が悪くて、不幸になっているならば、その人のせいだよ」
「なんで俺が助けてあげなくちゃあかんか」と。
では、例を出しましょうか。
今はないけれど例えば、結構仕事をして、会社でかなり仕事を、商売をやって、
金があった人が全部パチンコやら女遊びやら、いろんなものに、賭け事やら、
お金を全部使いきって、土地も売って、家も売って、ホームレスになっている。
家族も離れて「もう父親やと認めないんだ」と。そういう人を見たら、
「可哀そうこの人。食べるものも禄にないみたい。ではお金をあげて助けてあげましょう」
と思った瞬間で この人の性格を知ったならば
あげたくない気持ちが生まれてくるんですね。
こんなだらしない性格で、 家族も不幸に陥れちゃって
「ざまあみろ」という気持ちにならない？ なる場合もある。
（そこを私はもっと、）品のない例えをおいておき、
人の幸福は、その人が築くべきです、と。
だから、不幸になったら「さようなら、あなたのせいだよ」と。
「誰だって困っているから、助けは成り立たない。」というエライ哲学ですね。
「人っていうのは、誰だって困っているでしょう」と。
「問題かかえていない人間がいるの？」
「いないでしょうに」と。 私には、私なりの問題がいっぱいあるんだよ、と。
だから敢えて「他を助ける必要はないや」と、
そういうちょっと理屈っぽいアイデアを出して却下する人もいる。
その人々は、基本的に傲慢ですね。
「俺がエライ。自分の勝手で生きてますよ」と。
「誰のお世話にもなりませんよ」という、
全く変な考えを持っているのですね。
自分のことを高く評価している方々の問題です。
それで、自分のことを低く評価する人も人助けは、拒否する。
自分のことを高く評価している人は、人助けを拒否する。
人々はいろんな理由を言うのですよ。
どんな理由を言っても、この二つに分けることは出来ます。
そこで、もっとまとめてみると、これはエゴでしょう？
エゴは悪魔です。はい。
そのセクション終わりました。
別なことを考えましょうかね。上下関係。
困っていない人が困っている人を助けるでしょ？
例えば私はご飯をお腹いっぱい。
「あんたねぇ、あなたを助けたいのだから、このご飯を食べて下さい」
と出したとしても意味がないでしょう。
それで私がお腹が空いて困っている。
そこで余分に食べるものを持っている人がいる。
その人は「あの色々と余分に食べ物がありますから、
どうぞ、これ食べて下さい」と、その人は私を助けるでしょ？
そこで、困っていない人が困っている人を助けるのだから、
なんか、ちょっと上下関係が現れてしまうんです。
ですから、ちょっと、駄洒落なんですけど、次のフレーズはそんなに大した意味はないのですが
「人助けを実行するには、困っている人がいないと困りますよ」と。
これは世の中でよくあることなんです。
もう派手に人を助けて、組織的に人助けをやる、
いろんな組織がありますよ。
だから、結構、アメリカとかは、財産を子供にあげませんから、
全部色々な福祉システムに、教会に、あげちゃうんですね。
そういうシステムで、金持っていて、だから、金を頂くために、
何か看板をつけないと。
だから、アフリカのあるいは、どこかの子供たちに教育させます、とかね。
食事を十分食べるようにしてあげます、とかね。
あれやこれやと、組織的に人を助けるシステムもありますね。
そういう人々の立場から見ると、
例えば栄養失調で困っている子供たちに一食分あげましょうと。
私のところにも色々あったんだけど、100円くらいあれば、あなたが寄付すれば、
一人の子供には一食分出しますよ、と。
そうしたら私は出す気にはなりますけど
例えば地球上に栄養失調で困っている子供がいなかったらどうしますかね？
あの組織の人助けは、アウト、終わり。
例えば戦争の被害者を助けましょう、と。
戦争があるから、これで避難している人々、
ざーっと難民はたくさん出ますからね。
そこはたいへんでしょう。
隣の国に物凄い人々が難民として入ったら、どうしようもないのですよ。
あんたは、隣の国だから、入るなよ、ということも言えませんし、
そちら（の国に）は問題があるんだから。
だから国に入っても良いんだけど、この国の人々には、
この人々の住むところ、食べるもの、あれやこれや、薬などなど、
用意してあげることがまるっきりできなくなっちゃうんです。
国の財産をそういう風に考えてないでしょう。
そうすると世界的に色々な組織が行って助けてあげる。
家を作ってあげるわ、医療団が行って治療してあげるわ、
すごくカッコよく見えるでしょう。
かっこよく見えても、私は今、ちょっと文句言っているのは、
そういう風に、尊い行為をするために、
どこかの国が隣の国と殺し合いをやらなくちゃあかんでしょう？
ずっと我々が生きてきた時代にそういうことが起きたでしょう？
いつ見ても、どこかの国が隣の国と戦って殺し合いをやっちゃう。
そうすると、たくさんの難民が出てくる。
そこで助けてあげる。
そこで、私には矛盾が見えるのですね。
私は、人助けをしたい。
だから困っている人がいないのだから、困っているのだよ、と。
だから人助けを推進するために、困っている人の存在が必要なのですね。
これ、ちょっと論理的にヘンです。
では、観念的に。これはあり得ないんだから、観念的にね、
社会があらゆる面で、平等だと仮定しましょう。
これはあり得ないんですね、人類の歴史の中で。
これからもあり得ないのだけど、まぁ、ぴったり平等な人間社会。
そうすると、助けるという概念は？
関係のない概念になります。（「ない」が入っていない。）
関係外の。関係ない。助けなくて良いんです。
子供が宿題をしようとしたんだけど、鉛筆がなければ、
はい、鉛筆あげます、とできますよ。
或いは、「あなた、好きな鉛筆を何本でも買って下さい」といって、
お金をあげて「はい、店に行って下さい」と置くこともできる。
それには、子供が鉛筆がなくて困るという状態が必要なんです。
ちゃんと鉛筆ボックスを持って宿題をやってる子供に、
「あのね、この鉛筆、あんたにあげますから、これを使って下さい」
といっても「いらん」と言うんです、子供は。
人助けを応援して、社会を不平等のままに保つのでしょうか。
だから、人助けをしましょう、人助けをしましょう、と一方的に謳っても、
裏にあるのは、社会は不平等で、
困っている人があってほしい、ということにもなります。
そういうこともちょっと考えて下さい。
はい、次のスライドに行きます。
また別のテーマ。助けっていうのは、２種類あります。
イチ、物質的なもので助けること。
これはわかりやすい、説明する必要はないんですね。
例えば、ある国で、寒気で食料は全くなくて、
輸入するお金もない、といったら、
人間は飢え死にする訳にはいきませんから、物質をあげて、あげて
物質援助をして、良くなるまで命をつないでもらう、
という、これは物質的な助け。
病院を作ってあげたり、学校を作ってあげたり、色々。
助けてもらう人が少ない場合は問題ありません。
その場合は、物質をあげるでしょ？
助けてもらう人々が少ない。だったら大丈夫、やれます。
例えば、皆様の５人くらいね、食料不足で、
栄養失調になっている子供たちを助けたいと思って下さい。
そうすると、ある国で、百万人の子供たちが栄養失調で苦労してます。
何かできる？
５人にできることは、すごい小さいね。
だから、その物質の助けの場合は、
助けを受ける側の方が少ない方がうまく行くんです。
だから、我々は人助けをするならば、そこで、余計な結論を出しますけど、
我々の仕事は、物質的に、経済的に、困らない世界をつくることなんです。
でないと、これは成り立たないんです。
だから、コロナの問題でも、世界は攻撃を受けたんですね。
そうすると、知識人の、研究者の仕事は、政府の仕事は、
そういう訳のわからないウイルスが攻撃したら、
地球スケールでどうやって対応するのか、
ということをやらなくちゃいかんですよ。
困っている人が多数派になると、少数派に助けてあげることはできなくなります。
だから、具体的にそれを考えて下さい。
あんた、弁当100個くらい持っていて、あげましょう、
と行ってみたら、そちらには2,000人もいる。
困らない？
あ、2,000人分はないんだけど、100人にあげますよ、と。
困りますよ、どうやって100人を選ぶんですかね。
どんな基準で。困りますよ。
だから、そこは、物質助けの場合は、助けて頂く側が少ない方が、
やりやすいし、実行できるし、問題は解決します。
困っている人の方が多数で、助ける方が少数になってくると、アウト。
２番目の助けというのは、精神的な助け。
それは一番、仏教は推薦するもので、
食べるものがなかったら何とかすれば、
食べるものが手に入ることは出来るし、
それはそんなに大きな問題ではないのです。
世界の人間の生き方が悪いんだから世界が困っているでしょう。
性格が悪いんだから、ウクライナとソ連が殺し合いをやっているでしょう。
どちらも性格は悪い。
だから、人間らしくなりなさい、とソ連人にも、ロシア人にもウクライナ人にも
ちょっと教えてあげればどうなるんですかね。
情けないや、と。
怒り・嫉妬・憎しみ、捨てなさいよ、と。
ウクライナ人が偉くて、ロシア人が偉くないということはないんだ、と。
ロシア人がすごく体力が、でっかい国だから、
ウクライナなんか、なんだ気にするもんか、つぶしてやるぞ、という
そう思うことで、やっぱり思考が汚いね。
これはずーっと世界の状況を見ると分かるでしょう。
だから人間に必要なのは、本当の助け。
人間が人間らしく生きなさいよ、というアドバイスなんです。
恨むなよ、みんな兄弟ではないか、と。
民族差別するなよ、と。言語差別するなよ、と。
皮膚の色を差別するなよ、と。
科学的にみてみなさいよ、と。みんなホモサピエンスやと。
同じ仲間や、と。
そういう風にこの、考え方、アプローチ、
気持ち、そこを治せば、世界は幸せになるでしょ。
だから物質的に、あなたに食べ物をあげます、ということで、
あなたに飲み物をあげます、ということよりは、
この、精神の方がものすごく優れている。
そこで凄い影響力のある世界的に尊敬される一人の人間がいる、としましょう。
その人が世界に向けて講演をやったり色々みんなに
弟子をつくって「貴方がたも教えて下さい」
「みんな平和でいなくちゃあかんや」
「みんな平等であることは、
毎回毎回再確認、再確認で生きなくてはあかんや」と教えたらどうですかね。
だから一人の人間には人類を助けることはできますよ。
それは物質での助けではないのです。
本当の助けはそちらにあるのです。
はい、次のスライドに進みます。
言い忘れましたが、精神的に助ける場合は、助ける人は、それなりに
理性のある智慧のある性格の良い人格者になった方がよろしいんです。
ですから我々ひとりひとりが凄い人格者になったら
それだけで結構人々は助かっているんです。
次のアイデアはモティベーション、というところ。
モティベーションというのは、汚れたモティベーション、
清らかなモティベーション
それでモティベーションは、もうカタカナで分からなくて、
調べて調べて見付けて入れたのです。
モチベーションという（言葉を）。
モチベーションが汚れたとは。汚れたモチベーション。
日本語で、今日も朝、電話があって、ある人から、モチベーションあれやこれや、と言って、
あまりこのモチベーションだけで良いわけじゃない、っていうことをわかってないのですね。
あーモチベーションをあげましょう、とか言うだけなんです。
汚れた、とは。モチベーション、汚れたモチベーションとは、もう最悪。
だって、この人が頑張ってるんだから、モチベーションの刺激で。
でも、モチベーションが汚れてるんだったら？
自我、貪瞋痴などの感情があること。いろんな感情がありますね。
だいたい世間でモチベーションを掻き立てるために、感情を使うんですよ。
「あいつに負けるなよ」と。「お前ら強いぞ」と。
ある学校の野球の試合でも、うちの学校は一度も勝ったことがないんだから
「今度はもう日本一になりましょうよ」と。
「みんなかたっぱしから負けるようにしましょう」とかね。
そういうふうにモチベーションを繋げるんですね。
だから、モチベーション自体が汚れてるんです。
そういうモチベーションで、何か自分の方に見返りを期待します。
例えば、欲に、欲のモチベーションで人を助ける。
助けてから、その人から、何か見返りを期待するんです。
この、見返り期待してやる人助けは人助けですかね。
だから、見返りは色々。感謝で。
例えば、助けてあげたら、助けてもらった人はでっかい看板書いて
報賞状を書いて、派手に感謝すると、みんな大喜び。
それで人を助けることで、権力を期待する場合もある。政治家とか。
第三世界で、アジアとか。自分の国とか。
政治家が、悪得した金でちょびっと、ちょびっと誰かにあげて、
「それから自分に投票して下さい」と。
今回もお金を印刷して、大量に。
田舎でみんなに５千ルピー配って、
「自分の政党をしっかりしましょう」と。
ああいうのは、賛成する？　それで、お金、自分の国がよくやりますよ。
お金を印刷する。して、自分が選んだ人々に配る。
そのためにも人々は物凄く困ってないと困る。
だからスリランカでは、食べる物はない、ガソリンはない、電気はない。何もない。
水道の値段も、もう300％上げちゃったんです。
70ルピーとか80ルピー程度だった灯油を一日で、350ルピーにしちゃったんです。
それで人は困る。
それで一部選んで、ちょびっと何かあげて、うちの党を応援しなさい、と。
応援するどころか、殺すべきなんですけど、
そうやって汚れた自分の自利、自分の利益、自分の権力だけ握るために、
かなりのモチベーションでやる助けは助けじゃなくて、
だから、助けのように見える破壊活動が世の中にあるんです。
清らかなモチベーションというのは、慈悲喜捨です。
これは、すごいシンプルで、決まっている。
皆さま、欲のモチベーションは悪いでしょ？
では「私は、欲をなくしますよ」と。
これはそんな簡単じゃないよ、欲をなくすことは。
生きるために結構欲も必要でしょうし。
だから「欲を無くす」ということは智慧の活動で
迂闊に「はーい、今日から欲を無くします。怒りを無くします」
そんなあり得ないのです。それにはかなり心の法則を学ばないと
そうじゃなくて、欲がちょこちょこあっても良いんじゃないんですか。
ちょびちょび怒ってもまぁ良いんじゃないんですか、
ときどき、ではなくて、結構、アホなことをやっているとかね。
それはたまに、じゃないね。たまに欲張る、たまに怒るですけど、
アホなことはたまじゃなくて、結構やりますからね。
まぁそれはやっても、そもそも人間だからね。
そもそも人間だから、そこら辺は、理解して、
「慈悲喜捨」を実践する、慈悲喜捨のモチベーションをつくる。
それが清らかなモチベーションです。
そこで慈悲喜捨の気持ちで人を助けると自分も助かっているのです。
結果は瞬間で得られます。
だから、人助けは赤字になる行為ではないんです。
一万円で人を助けたら、自分がそれによって得る精神的な幸福感は、
一千万円でも買えませんよ。
いくら、お金がいくらあっても、幸福感を買えますかね？
これを貰いますからね、だから慈悲喜捨のモチベーションは仏教は推薦します。
なぜかというと、他宗教も、人助けは、どんな宗教も謳ってるフレーズです。
しかしそちらは「神様」という奴がいるんだから、
清らかなモチベーションは作りにくい。はい。
では敢えてまた、同じことの繰り返しになるのですが、まぁ、
仏教の見方ということになります。
（法輪が切られてますけどね。これ全部入れようと思っても、このプログラムではできませんでした。）
まずあの、また繰り返しになります。
人助けのgeneral standpoint、一般的な見解。
命は因果法則の結果です。
これ、皆様、仏教は嫌いかもしれませんけど、興味あるでしょ？
仏教と言うのは因果法則を教える教えなんです。
大乗仏教でも竜樹という人が、ブッダは因果法則を説いた、
というところで、自分の作品を始めたんです。
最初にそのフレーズを書いて。
因果法則は、誰にも否定できません。それは真理です。
そこで、例えばこの体の中で、自分の命以外に無数の生命がいるでしょう。
かなりいますよ。自分の体重を計ってみたら、
65キロだといったら、大体５キロくらいは微生物の重さなんです。
だからそういう微生物がいなかったら、このシステムは成り立たないんです。
食べても消化できないのです。
ですから、命とは、これは厳しいフレーズで覚えてほしい
単独・単立では成り立ちません。
新幹線にでも乗ったら考えて下さい。
私はお金を払って乗りましたよ、と。そうですかね。
どれほどの人々の協力、どれほどの知識人の、
エンジニアたちの努力が、そちらにあるんでしょうかね。
だから、ちゃんとチケットを入れたら入った、
改札口から自分の座席に座ったというのは、シンプルな行為ですけど、
想像できないくらいのシステムで起きてる僅かな出来事です。
はい。他の生命の助け・協力、（また漢字が間違ってます）
他の生命の助け・協力・支えは最大です。
本当に自分の力で生きるということは、どこまでかと分からないくらい小さいんです。
例えば手で食べるものを取って口に入れる。
噛んで飲み込んでからは、自分の管轄外でしょ？
助けてくれるんでしょう。
自分がやったのは、手で口に入れて、噛んで飲み込んだだけ。
だから協力は必要です。体も、知識も、外から頂いているのです。
この肉体は、頂いたものです。
最初の細胞を母親、父親からもらったり、それから、チキンやら
キャベツやらご飯やら、いろんな物質を入れて、
入れて組み立てたものです。
からだも借りたものです。完全に借りたものです。
細胞一個も無いんです、私の細胞、というのは。
「これは私が過去世から持ってきたんだよ」と。それはないんです。
では知識はどうですかね？
生まれた時は何も知らなかったでしょう？
我々の知識は全て、頂いて、頂いて。
生きている限り、借りる流れが続きます。
死ぬ瞬間まで、借りる、借りる、借りる、借りる、借りる、なのです。
自分が他の生命、自然環境を助けることは、わずかなお返しになります。
（なんかじわじわとマイクロフォンから離れていたんですね。
もしかすると、音が聞こえなかったかも。もう年寄りだから、そういうこともあります。）
ですから、生まれて、お腹に母体に誕生した瞬間から、
死ぬ瞬間まで借りる、借りる、借りる、借りる、借りる、借りる、借りる、この流れが続きます。
仏教的に、死んでから再び転生したと云っても同じこと。
また借りる流れなんです。
ですから、ちょっとこの循環を、ちょっと変えるためには、
我々は「返す」ということをするんです。
それは助けなのです.
ですからこの場合は、「人」助けだけではなくて、
自分の命を支えた「環境」に何かしらを助けなくてはあかんです。
川の水をきれいにすること、山をきれいに守ること、
空いてる土地でいろんな植物を植えること、それもお返しです。
なんでも良いのです。その分自分の命の続きも保証されます。
ですから人助けではなくて私は言葉を入れ替えるのです。
「返す」という借りを。
「借りを返す」という単語は、より仏教的なのです。
そうなってくると、やっぱり、借金を返す人は不幸にならないでしょ？
どうしても借金しなくてはいけない状態で
商売始めたいし、家を作りたいし、それで借金します。
それは悪いことではないのです。
しかし分割でも良いのですから、返した方が良いのですね。
だから、幸福を保障するために、生きる喜びを保障するために
明るく生きるためには、我々は人助けに言葉を入れ替えて「返す」。
「借りを返す」という言葉にして頂いた方が良いのではないか、と思います。
そういう訳でこれって当たり前なんですよ。
大袈裟に考えないで下さい。人助け、ボランティアでしたっけ、日本語で。
（変な別のイメージが湧きますけど。）ボランティア活動などなどね。
大袈裟じゃないよ、こんなのは。
当たり前の行為です。借りを返すことは当たり前の行為です。
しかし完全に返すことは現実的に不可能です。
完全に返せません。
だから、この地球には、あと百年くらい経つと、
人間の命を支えることは出来なくなるんです。
人間は頑張ってますよ、自然を守ろう、自然を守ろう、と。
ほんのわずかな努力しかやってないんです。
だからそこから見ても、例えば我々人間が生きるために、
どれくらい地球の土地を破壊したんですかね。
東京では、もう全部土地の上にビルを建てているでしょ？
土地はそのまま更地であった方が、地球が、
なんて言いますか、命を元に戻すのです。
でもこちら、コンクリートで閉めちゃうでしょ。
なんか殺生するような感じなんです。
ですから、それって仕方がないことで、東京はたくさん人が住んでいるのだから、
たくさん建物・ビルなども必要になっちゃうし、
だから、それでも我々は一部、一部でも返さなくちゃいけないんです。
完全に返すことはできないのです。
ですから、やがて人類は滅びます、頑張っても。
これは避けられないんです。
例えわずかでも借りを返しましょう。はい。
より仏教の深いところに入ります。覚醒するための修行。
覚醒というのは、解脱に達すること、覚ることなのですね。
そちらに修行しなくてはあかんですね。
仏教では、お釈迦様が覚る前に菩薩でいた、というストーリーがあるのです。
菩薩というのは、覚りを目指して生きている人、
それは自分だけのために生きてることではないのです。
無始なる過去から菩薩が修行してきたんです。
そういうエピソード、ま、作り話も結構あると思いますけど、
エピソードがテキストになって、文学としてあるんです。
その菩薩の過去世物語を見ると、
テーラワーダの人たちはジャータカ物語という言葉で知っています。
ジャータカ物語をなんか、いい加減ちょこちょこっと開けて読んでみて下さい。
菩薩は何かしら、自分の修行として人を助けているのです。
そこで、『人助け』というのを、仏教は二重構造で考えるのです。
人を助けて、自分もその結果良い人間になる。
例えば人に「ご飯を食べなさい」と。
「あんたは生活に困っているから、いくらか援助します」と言って、
同時に「あ、損しました」ではなくて、
自分の人格、自分が欲の少ない人間になろうとする。
だから本当の人助けというのは、そういう二重構造なんです。
自分が未熟なままで人を助けても、それは人助けにならないのです。
自分が人を助けることによって、自分の人格も向上していく
そうすると正しいのです。
それは、お釈迦様が明確に説かれているポイントなのです。
他人を助けることで、人は覚者になる資格を得ます。
そこで、覚るために、覚ることは、すごい智慧が必要でしょうし
修行しても智慧が開いてこない場合もあるしね。
だからその能力、智慧が開発される、この法則。
まず、一般仏教では、徳を積んでないとダメ、ということなのです。
徳を積んだ人は、瞑想したら覚ります。
瞑想しても覚らない人は、徳が足らない。
これは一般俗世間に、そういう単語で言いますよ。
その方が理解しやすい。ちょっと差別用語ですけど、それは。
人に「あんた徳を積んでないんだからね」と言ったらね。
私は言いませんけどね。といっても言う可能性もあります。（笑）
そこで、私たちは、お釈迦様に説かれた通りに
人を助けることは当たり前、借りて生きている。
完全に返せませんが、とにかくギリギリまで返す、と。
そうすると自分の人格が向上する。
それはすごい自分がポテンシャルパワーをもってるのです。
その他の生命と違うのです。
ただの毛虫ではないのです。
毛虫は葉っぱを食っちゃう。食っちゃうと、
植物にとって、毛虫がいても、なんの役にも立たない。
葉っぱを食っちゃうだけだから。しかしミツバチが来ることはどうですかね。
植物にとってありがたいことなんです。
ミツバチは、自分の花の蜜とポラン（花粉）をもっていきますよ。
それで、ミツバチも助かっているし、その植物も助かっているでしょ？
そういうことで、この正しい方法で、
我々は、人を助けるということは修行ですね。この、修行を実行すると
自分にはポテンシャルが起きて起きて、瞑想したらピシャッと智慧が開きます。
単純利他行を否定されています。
だから本当の助けというのは、他を助けて、自分も助かる。
そうすると、（人助けというのは）いくらでもできる。
助けてあげればあげるほど、自分も助かっている。
だから「助けて私は損しました」ということは、
あまり、ブッダの仏教では、無いのです。
単純利他行を否定されています。
他を助けることで、自分のエゴが弱くならなくてはいけません。
はい、では結論として覚えてください
「我々はなぜ人を助けるのか」というと、
自分のエゴを金づちで叩いて叩いて破るためなんです。
はい、次にいきます。
はい、なんか入ったのだから、この「自利と利他」という、これから、
食い過ぎて暇のあるお坊さんたちが昔よく議論したテーマなのです。
食い過ぎた、と思いますよ。
なぜならば、議論するだけで、非難侮辱するだけで、
誰も答えが見付らないんです。
昔のお偉い開祖様だと言っても、バカはバカです。
一部の仏教徒たちは、「利他」のみが大乗で、
小乗仏教は「自利」に専念していると思っています。
『利他』というのは、他人の幸福のために頑張ること、
『自利』というのは、自分の幸せを目指して頑張ること。
だから「うちは利他行で頑張ってる大きなブッダの道をやっているのだ」と言って
「あの人たちは自分の修行をやってるのだから自利行で小乗や」と。
それであの人々は差別しているでしょ？
それってやってはいけないことでしょう、仏教で。
だからバカなんですよ。
食い過ぎちゃったら、寝ていれば良かったのに。
余計なことをして。
仏教の哲学って、ハチャメチャなのです。
この区別は明確な差別です。
「自利」と「利他」はひとつの行為です。
それを解っていないのです。
これは二つの行為ではないのです。
ひとつの行為です。分離できません。
自分が良い人間になることで、他の生命も助かります。
例えばよく我々に言う悪口は、自分たちで、何かしら知らんだけど、
戒律を守ったりして、まぁ、どこかで隠れて瞑想したりしている、
ま、暗い連中や、と。
考えて下さい。
人は戒律を守ると、人類の助けにならない？
例えば、私は絶対に嘘をつかないことにしましょう。
言ったら、私に関係ある人々はみんな助かっているでしょう。
私は全く与えられていないものを取らないことにする。
それだったら、私の前にいる人々は、自分の財産に対しては、
なんの心配もなく、いられます。管理任せ（られ）ます。
では、与えられていないものは何も取らない人だったら
自分たちがどこかへ出掛ける、１週間。
あのね、「自分の家ちょっと、1週間なんとか（みて）やってくれませんか」と。
水をやらなくちゃいけないし、あれやる、これやる、とかあるんだけどね。
「あぁいいよ」と。
その人が、その金持ちの金庫が開けたままであっても、
そちらで、宝石・ダイヤがいっぱいあっても、触らない。
だから信頼できるでしょ？
だから結局は、自分が戒律を守ることで、
ちゃんと人類が助かるんです。
他人を助けたり、他人の悩み・苦しみをなくすために、
努力すると、自分自身も助かって、自分の悩み苦しみもなくなります。
だから人が悩んでいると何とか助けてあげて、
よく話し合って「 あーそういうことですねぇ、
やっぱりまぁそういうことで悩んだから」と言って、
「あんたが苦労するだけでね、まぁ気にしないことにしましょう」
気になるならば私はあなたと一緒にいますよ。
「一緒にゲームでもやりましょうよ」と。
そういう風に、（その人の）悩んでいる人を助けると、自分にも同じことが起きちゃうと、
もう（自分には）力があるのです。「あぁ、こんなことではくよくよ悩みません」と。
だから、これは自利、利他同じものなんです。
そこでまた、私も悪口を言っているスライドです。
自利・利他を分けちゃうと、カットしちゃうと、矛盾になるんです。
自分のことを後回しにして、他を助ける。
大乗と名乗っているグループはね。
観音さんもそうでしょ？
最後の生命が解脱に達するまで、自分の解脱を後回しにする、と。
生命は、無数・無限にいるんだから、
あの人には永久的に解脱に達することはできないんです。
かわいそうや、と思いますけどね。
だから、観音は実在しないんだから、良いんだけど、
このいい加減、食い過ぎちゃって論理するなよ、と私は言いたいんです。
人を助けることだけ優れていると言ったら、
人を助ける、人を助ける、人を助ける。
やりきれない、自分を助けてないんです。
だから、だらしないままで死んでしまいます
仕事も完了していないんです。
もしかすると、ちょっと云い過ぎ。
「私の修行は人を助けることや」と言っちゃうと、
聞いた人、「ああ分かりました」
私も人を助ける、私も人を助ける、人類は人を助けることになっちゃったら、
助けてもらう人は一人もいなくなっちゃうんです。
みんなだらしない人間になる、 だって、自分の修行を後回しにしてますからね。
だから利他行を謳っちゃうと見事な矛盾にぶつかるんです。
逆も同じです。
小乗仏教は自利のために頑張るということはね。
そこも、極論になってくると矛盾です。
ですから、例えばこういうこと。
ま、読みますからね。飛ばしましょう。 他人のことはどうでも良い。
私は自分の解脱を目指すというスタンスであるならば、
自我の錯覚は破れません。
だって、なんで小乗仏教の人々は瞑想するのか、というと、覚りたいんです。
人のことを構っている場合じゃない、オレが覚らなくちゃあかんや、と。
やっちゃうと覚れないんです。だって、自我だから。
だから利他行だけカットしちゃうと矛盾です。
自利行だけカットしちゃうと矛盾です。
どちらも地獄に落ちるんです。
それは言い過ぎのまあ、おもしろフレーズです
あんまり真剣に聞かないで下さい。
だから、自利自他同じやと理解しなくちゃだめなんです。はい、次にいきます。
次のテーマは、There are limits.
何にでも、因果法則だから、制限があります。
各生命は自分の業を持っている。
全ての生命には、自分のものと言えるのは業です。
それによって、幸福を感じる。
人の業を変えることは不可能です。
他人にそれを変えることはできない。
これは、その人の特有のパワーです。
他人にあげることはできないし、何もできません。
ですから、人助けだとしても、完全に助けてあげることは成り立ちません。
リミットがあるんです。
じゃあ、すごい悪い例を出しましょう。
人が生まれて、その人は目がみえない。
目が不自由。
やっぱり目が見える我々は助けなくちゃあかんでしょ？
助けてあげる。
助けてあげても、あげても、あの人の目がずーっと死ぬまで見えないでしょ？
変えられません。他は点字を教えてあげたり、
学問を教えてあげたり、
いろんな方法で助けてあげることはできます。
本を読んであげたり、でも目が見えないことは、
これは業の結果ですからどうしようもないんです。
ですから我々は、人を助ける場合でも、必ず、制限があるんだよ、と。
限りなく人助けっていうのは成り立たないです。
しかし、自分の業を改善・改良する方法は教えられます。
仏教になってくると、またちょっと救いがあります。
ちょっと業が弱くて困っている人がいるとしましょう。
それで誰かお坊さんが、私ではなくてね、誰か、頭の良いお坊さんがいて、
その人の業は、こういうことで、困っていると分かるんですね。
分かって色々アドバイスするんです。
こうしましょう、こうしましょう、こういうことをしましょうとかね。
そのアドバイスで、その人がやるならば、自分の業が改良・改善するんです。
だから自分の業が改良・改善になったら、その分、幸せになるんです。
だから人の業を変えるためには、出来ることは、アドバイスだけです。
それも仏教を知っている人でなければ無理、不可能です。
人を解脱に導くという最高の人助け
お釈迦様がやった人助け、これは究極の人助け。
輪廻転生で苦しんでいる人々に、解脱の安穏を見せます。
経験させます。しかし制限があります。そちらにも。
お釈迦様は解脱に達する「道」を教える。
問題があったら答えてあげる、
協力する、しかし、その本人が修行しなくちゃあかんです。
だからブッダにできることは教えることだけです。
解脱させる、ハンコ押すように、「はい、おいで、パーン」
「あんた解脱」それは無いんです。
それだったら、ある宗派があります、日本で。
（そちらに）行ってください。ハンコを押してくれます。
結果は相手の努力と精神力によって左右されます。
例えば、我々は一方的に言いますよ。
究極の人助けはブッダの真理を教えること。
人々に道徳を守らせること、人々に瞑想を教えること。
瞑想する時に起きる問題を解決してあげること。
それは最高やと思っているんだけど、
しかし本人の努力によって結果が左右されます。
いつだって、there are limits.ということを覚えて下さい。
そろそろ終わりやと思います。
はい、理性的な人助け。
肉体は必ず壊れますが、精神は生滅変化しながら続くんです。
心を清らかにすることは優れた行為です。
そこで順番があります。
イチ、自分（え？へへへ。面白いフレーズですからね、消してほしくないね。）
自分が善い人間になる、他人にもその道を教える。例えば犬猫でも、
早く死んじゃうし、からだが苦労して、いろいろ問題があっても、
気持ち良くいること、明るい気持ちでいることはさせられますよ。
ですから、こころを清らかにすることは、一番トップの人助けなんです。
それで、自分がまず清らかなこころをつくらなくちゃ。
そこはもう、それが、なんと言いますか、これがネックなんです。
自分がいくらかこころ清らかになってから、人にもそれを教える。
例えば、最後に書いたフレーズは面白いでしょ？
「私は激怒しますが、あなたは怒りを収めて下さい」と
言ったら、殴られるかもね。これは成り立たない。
「私は滅多なことでは怒りませんよ、これで幸せや」と。
「あなたも怒らないように頑張ってみたらどうですか？」と。
この、こころを清らかにする助けは、こういう順番があるんです。
まず自分、それから他人。
これはこの、部派仏教の方々は相当勘違いしちゃったんです。
これは順番です。
それで「私は欲張りですけど、あなたは欲を収めて下さい」と。
馬鹿にされますよ。だからお釈迦様は、順番を教えていますよ。
例えば煩悩をなくす場合でも、自分が泥沼に沈んでいて、
泥沼に沈んだ隣の人を助けられませんよ、と。
まず自分があがって下さい、と。
あがって手を伸ばして下さい、と。
それが順番なんです。はい。
そういう訳で、結局は自分の修行っていうことになるんです。
人助けは自分自身の修行になります。
人助けっていうのは、人助けじゃなくて、自分の修行です。
人を助けても完全に助けることはできません。覚悟して下さい。
完全に助けることはできません。
子供はとても良い学校に入れることはできますよ、親に。
でも、そいつが勉強しなければどうしますかね。
しかし他人を助ける行為によって、自分が良い人間になります。
とにかく人を完全に助けてあげることはできませんだけど、
できませんというのは、制限がありますけど、
助けることによって、自分が立派な人間になっていくんです。
そちらに制限がないんです。解脱に達するまで、自分が向上します。
欲、怒り、無知、わがまま、感情に負けること、自我中心になることなどが、
徐々にこころから離れます、人を助けると。
なんか、みるみるうちに自分の汚れが落ちているんです。
結局のところ、他を助けることは、自分を助けることにもなるんです。
わからなくなっちゃうんですよ、私はこの人を助けたか、
自分自身を助けて貰ったか、よう分からんや、と。
それくらい、これが溶けるんです、人助け。
助けを求める人がいることを、
両者が共に良い結果を出すチャンスにするのが、理性的です。
だから上下関係じゃないんです。助けを求める人がいる、
助けられる人がいる、では、これは良いチャンスや、と言って二人とも立ち上がることです。
あなたのおかげで私は良い人間になっちゃった、と。
オレが助けてあげたでしょ？ではないんです。
上下はないんです。
じゃあまあ、纏めましょう。
人助けっていうのは、ややこしいでしょ？
覚えて下さい。慈悲喜捨の実践です。とてもシンプルです。
こちら二つあります。イチ、全ての生命は自分と等しい存在である、
という実感が現れるまで、自分で慈悲の瞑想をするんです。感じるんです、
全て生命は同じや、と。
それから、自分の能力に適した人助けを具体的にやるんです。
それはいつでも制限があるんだからね。
完全に助けてあげることはできませんだから。
でも、精神的に、一切生命は幸せでありますように、と思うことは出来ます。
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように、と念じる。
念じることは可能ですが、
実行するときは一部の生命が対象になります。当たり前でしょ。
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと、
ちょっと幸せにしてあげたいと具体的にやっちゃうと、
一部の生命になるんです。
解脱に達した方も、慈悲喜捨を実践します。
だから、解脱に達して、阿羅漢になって、
仏陀になっても、まだ生きてるんだからね。
まだ、借りてるんです。ですから、慈悲喜捨を実践するんです。
勝れた人助け。これはちょっと、add onで、もう講演は終わったんだけど、
ちょっと加えたんです。（終わったのを？）忘れちゃってね。
これ、使っているのは、人助けを完成することはできないということを覚えていて下さい、という意味なんです。
これは、お釈迦様の言葉から借りたんです。
親の恩はいくら頑張っても返しきれないのだと仏陀が説く。
大げさに言ってますよ。両親を肩に乗せてずっと面倒みてあげるんだ、と。
でもそんなことで親孝行したことにならんや、と。
やっぱり、皆様にできますかね。
皆様の父親、母親が、皆様にしてあげたこと、
その人に返すこと、不可能でしょ。
だから親孝行、ボツにする？
やめる？それもだめです。
これ、親の例でポイントを理解しましょう。
親が私にしてあげたことは、私に親に返せないんです。
それぐらい命を守って来たんです。
いつでも、自分のことをおいておいて、
子供のことを先に出すんですよ。
それは親しかやらないこと。
だから、親の恩は返せない恩、ということになってます。
しかし、お釈迦様はこう言うんです。
しかし親が悪から離れるようにすること。
お父さん、悪行為はもういいんだからやめようね、とか。
悪から離れること、善行為を行うように助けること。
例えばお父さんがだらしないんだったら、
「お父さん、あちらどこかで説法会があるんだから、
私が連れて行きますから、一緒に行きましょうよ」とかね。
つまらなかったら、お父さん、途中で寝ても良いんだから、というか、
そうやっていろんな工夫して善行為をさせる。
親のこころの煩悩をなくすために助けること、
親を解脱に導くこと、
それが完璧な恩返しになるんです、とお釈迦様は仰っています。
そこでわかるでしょ、人助けっていうのは、そんな大したことができない、と。
リミットがあるんです。本当に助けたければ、相手のこころを清らかにするようにと、
アドバイスしてあげることです。そちらに協力してあげることです。
この教えで何よりも「優れた人助け」は、どういうことかと理解できますね。
こころが完全に煩悩から離れたら、
その人は、完全に、一切皆苦という苦から離れます。はい、以上ですね。
ℚ：質問がふたつだけあります。宜しくお願いします。
ひとつは、こちらで勉強するようになって、殺生はいけません、ということで、
最初は簡単に、人殺しのことを言っているんだな、と思って、
そんなのしないよ、簡単だよ、と思ったんですけど、全ての生命ということで、
虫も入る、ということだったので、すごく悩んでいることがひとつあります。
職業柄、いま保育士をしているんですけれども、子供たちがよく蚊に刺されるんですね。
それで、子供によってはすごく腫れて、親御さんに謝罪しなければいけないこともあって、
お散歩中に蚊を見ると悩んでいます、すごく。ここで叩いて良いものか、
取り敢えずはたいて、違う人に行ってほしいな、という風に葛藤している時があります。
今のところ殺さないで、逃げてほしいという感じで、はたいてはいるんですけれども、
子供たちを刺されないようにしてほしいというのもあって、ちょっと悩んでいるところです。
もう一つの質問は、他の場所で、悟りの段階が52段階あったのですが、
こちらでは、（悟りの段階は）4段階ということで、今、長老さんはどの段階にあたるのでしょうか。よろしくお願いします。
あまり聞き取れなかったので、ちょっと。
今保育士をされていて、それでお子さんたちを色々と外に連れていったりする時に、
蚊に刺されないように気を付けているそうです。
ですが、その時に、どうしても蚊を叩きたくなってしまう。
今のところは叩かないで追い払うようにしているんですけど、
やはり親御さんたちからは、子供が蚊に刺されないようにしてほしいということで、すごく
言われたりするので、そこで、悩んでいる、ということです。
Ａ:これはね、子供たちに、ちょっとおもしろい形で箒みたいなもの、
ブラシみたいなものあるでしょ？パソコンのキーボードを（掃除するような）。
ああいうものをみんなに１本あげて蚊が来たらこれで追い払って下さい。
あるいは団扇でも宜しいしね、小さな。
じゃ、みんなに自前の団扇を買って、で子供たちは面白くて、
これで蚊を追っぱらっていると思いますよ。
だからそういうこともひとつの子供たちの教育に使えるんです。
親がわがままで、うちの子には蚊が刺されないようにしてください、と言ったら、
じゃ、うちの子に、あなたの子に何かかけて持って来て下さいと。
蚊くらい刺されたっても死にはせんや、と。
世の中のことに子供たちは慣れなくちゃあかんや、と教えてなくちゃあかんです。
はい、まだもうひとつあったっけ？
以前こちらの方が勉強していた仏教では、悟りの段階が52段階あったそうです。
それで、こちらでテーラワーダの方を勉強したら、悟りの段階は4段階だと
お聞きしましたと。ところで長老はどの段階にいるのですか、という質問です。
A:残念ですね。段階はないんですね。それはまあ、理屈に成り立たない言葉ですね。
これは差別世界で、いくら頑張ってもね、差別のない世界で、言葉も何も成り立たないんです。
他に質問ある方いらっしゃいますか？
Q:宜しくお願いします。Metta suttaṃ メッタスッタン、慈経の言葉の中に、
Santussaサントゥッサという、仏教用語で知足という言葉があるんですけれども、
この言葉の『知足のこころ』というものを成長させたり育てるために、
何か良いヒントがあったらアドバイス頂けたらお願いします。
Metta suttaṃ （メッタスッタ）に出てくるSantussa（サントゥッサ）という知足の教え、その項目を育てるために必要なことは何ですか？
Ａ：まぁ、知足は一番簡単でしょ？私とは、今の瞬間で得るものは決まっているしね。
今の瞬間で喋っているいるんだから、この音を聞くしかないでしょ？
知足というのは、自然法則で、今の瞬間に自分に触れているもの。
これは嫌だ、と思っても意味がないでしょ？
今の瞬間に呼吸しているのは、このホールにある空気でしょうに。
今の瞬間に肌に触れているのは、この空気の温度でしょうに。それだけ。
あー、もっと暖かい空気が欲しい、もっと、滑らかな空気がほしいや、とか、
もっと香りのついてた空気が欲しいとか、くだらんことを思うのは病気ですから、だから知足は至って簡単です。
タクシーに乗ろう、と思ったら、なかなか10分待ち、15分待ち。今は携帯で呼べますけど、
15分待ちで、ま、いいや、駅まで歩いても10分だからね、
じゃ歩きます、と。そんなもんが知足なんです。
お腹が空いて食べるものを探したら、白いご飯「しか」ないんです。
どうしますかね。ビーフステーキを妄想する？
料理の名前を分からないんだけどね、
焼き肉を妄想する？
白いご飯しかなかったら、それを食べて、はい、終わり、と。
至って簡単。今の瞬間に自分の眼耳鼻舌身に触れるものは、もう触れちゃっているんだから、
それで、ま、しょうがない、それだけや、と。
座っている椅子にトゲでもあったら、お尻が痛いでしょ？
その場合は他の椅子があったら、椅子を入れ替えても良いんです。
それは問題ないんです。それでも椅子は全部いっぱい。無い。
自分はこちらに座るしかない。だったら、トゲをちょっと何とか、
お尻の４分の１くらい使って座るんです。
そういうことですよ、至って簡単です。
Ｑ：お話の最後の方で、自分の能力に適したことで、人助けをするというお話があったと思うんですけど、
自分がどんなことに適しているかを考えるヒントなどありますでしょうか?
自分に適している人助けということを知るためのヒントになるものを何か。
Ａ：いらん、いらん、自分に何ができるか、自分で知っているでしょ、私は知りませんよ。
自分で出来ることは何でも良いんです。必要としている人があったら、
それをちょっと、助けてあげて下さいよ。至って簡単それも。
できないことは頑張らない方が良いんです。
誰かグループが「歌ってほしいな」と言ったら「ごめんね」と言っちゃえば終わりです。
私は歌えないんだけど、お話できますからね、
じゃ、５分くらい、お話でもします、と言って、いろんなネタを入れてお話してあげる。
だから、自分にできることはそういうことでしょ。
人を助けるために特別な訓練はいらない。
これ、怪しい、特別な訓練すること自体が。
それは職業になるんですね。
女の人は、看護大学を出たら、どうやって人にアプローチするのか、
どんな言葉を交わすのか、とか、それは訓練を受けますよ。
それはまあ職業であって、人助けかどうかは判らないんですね。
人助けというのは、自分が持っているものを何か役に立つ場合には使う。
まぁ必要としない場合は黙っている。
私の場合でも、私は結構仏教のことを結構知ってますけどね。
電車に乗ったら、誰かが話しかけてきたら、
「解脱に達する道をあなたに教えてあげます」と教えませんよ。
その時、その人が喋ったことに対応して、面白く答える。
はいそれだけですよ。
あまり真剣に考えないで下さい。
真剣に考えるとまずい結果になります。
とにかく、気楽に生きてみましょうよ。
人助けという膨大な、重い課題を背負う必要はないんです
軽く、軽く生きるんです。
すごく人生を軽くしましょう。
人生を軽くしている人が、周りにもどうせ、それだけでも助かります。
Ｑ：本日のお話で、親を解脱に導くことが最高の恩返しである、勝れた人助けである、というお話がありましたが、
正直申し上げて、すごく難しいな、と思いまして、理性的な人助けで、一番目に自分が良い人間になることで、二番目に他人に道を教える、と。
確かにお話ではございましたが、それを言ったところで、ちょっと、解脱に導けるかな、と一瞬思ってしまいまして、
解脱に導く、もう少し具体的なところを教えて頂くと助かります。電車では教えて頂けないそうですが、ここではちょっとお願いします。
親を解脱に導くことが最高の人助けである、とお話がありましたが、
どうもなかなか難しそうだな、と。もう少し具体的なヒントがあれば、教えて頂けないでしょうか。
A:私は言ったでしょ。There are limits！
何にしても、親に解脱の道案内をするのは本当の恩返しですけど、There are limits！。
親がまるっきり興味ないならば、また、親にその徳がなければ、
能力もなければ、まあ、どこまで良い親に、心清らかにするのか、という程度で止めなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから、理想があっても、完成にまではいかんでしょうに。
いつでも、何か、どこかで、もしかすると、例えば親が、
じゃあ、私もちょっと仏教を学びましょう、とか、
瞑想でもやってみようか、と言ったら、
親は、年を取ってるんだから、突然病気になったらどうしますかね。
病院に運んであげなくちゃあかんでしょうに。
だから、世の中はそういうものなんです。
よく日本でよく言うでしょ？
親孝行をしたいと思ったところで親はいない、と。
まあそういうことで。自分には親孝行したい気持ちが生まれるけど、親がとっくに他界していない、
そこでも、親の恩に気付くと親がいないとかね。
親がいる間は、もう恨みばっかりで、喧嘩ばっかりでね。
それって世の中のことなんですね。
助けるのは有難い、理想的なことを云うのは、仏教の仕事なんです。
例えば、仏教の立場で云うならば、人間に生まれたら、みんな解脱を目指した方が究極の幸せや、
と言ってはいるんだけど、仏教に興味を持っているのは、もう、ほんの、わずかな、わずかな人々でしょう。
だからそれで私たちは落ち込んだりもしませんし、話を聞く人に教える。
そういうことで、例えば自分にできることは全部やったのか、というと、やってないんです。
何か、何か、その時その時の因果法則の関係でできることをやっているだけです。
そういうことで。これ、必ず義務でやらなくちゃ、ということではないんですね。
あるんだけど、リミットがあります。制限がありますね。
だからやろうと頑張ってみて下さい。失敗したら、別に（それでも）良いんじゃないですかね。はい、以上です。
Q:今日はありがとうございました。今日のＣＧに映っておりました、命の法則というのがありまして、
その４番目に幸福を求める人、理性的な人は、ローンを返すように努める、とか。
あるいは、理性的な人たち、といった言葉があったんですが、
この理性的という言葉は、日本語としては何となく分かるんですが、
お釈迦様の説法、お釈迦様の経典では、この理性とか、理性的、という言葉に対応するパーリ語は何なんでしょうか。
本日のスライドの中で、「理性的」という言葉が何度か出てきました。
日本語としてのニュアンスはよく分かるのですが、お釈迦様が説法されたパーリ語で「理性的」に対応する言葉は何なんでしょうか。
よくあるのは、「viññūpuriso（ヴィンニュープリソー）」なんですね。
viññūpuriso（ヴィンニュープリソー）
レベルを高くすると『真理を学んだ人』というんだけど『 聖者たちの教えを学んで教育を受けた人』という、それはちょっとレベルが高いんです。
一般的に言うのは、viññūpuriso（ヴィンニュープリソー）『少々理性ある人』という意味なんですよ。
人間というのは、自分で理性があると思っているんだけど、我々は感情で生きているんですよ。
理性ではなくて。だから、この感情と理性を合わせて考えれば良いんです。
パーリ語の言葉は、viññū（ヴィンニュー）viññūpuriso（ヴィンニュープリソー）という言葉なんですね。